[موسيقى]
كنت أسير في صالة الألعاب الرياضية من أحد
طرفي المدرسة إلى الطرف الآخر في
الصباح
حوالي الساعة السابعة والربع صباحًا وكان هناك كرة سائبة
في الطرف الآخر ، لذا التقطتها
وذهبت وأخذت الكرة ، لقد
لعبت بشكل رائع  الكرة المدرسية في
الفناء الخلفي كان بها الكثير من الأصدقاء الذين
لعبوا الكرة ، لم أقم بالتسديد منذ
فترة طويلة ،
لكن الأمر ليس كما لو أنني أجعلها 100 من
الوقت
الذي كان فيه محظوظًا جدًا ، فأنا محظوظ جدًا
[موسيقى]
عندما  اعتدنا على التنظيف بعد
مباريات كرة السلة ، مع الأوصياء الآخرين
وأنا ، كنا نأخذ بضع لقطات
بعد أن ننتهي
، وقد قاموا جميعًا بتصوير
[الموسيقى]
بأنفسهم تحدثت إلى مديري
ومشرفي المباشر وليس هناك
سيكون
أي إجراء تأديبي على الإطلاق بالنسبة لي أثناء
التقاط هذه اللقطة ،
لا أعتقد أنهم جميعًا يعتقدون أنه من
المضحك أنه كان ممتعًا جدًا